[Music]
hey
it's us once again it's wednesday sorry
i'm like really really sleepy poopy woke
me up at two o'clock in the morning yeah
she woke us both up
she decided for whatever reason she's
like hey i'm gonna jump up on you to sit
on your chest and like
yeah i love you i'm gonna talk to you
i'm like i love you too honey
yeah and then i was i woke up i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on
we went to sleep kind of early so i had
a problem going back to bed
i woke up at two and then i didn't get
back to bed about four
yeah i didn't fall asleep again until
about 4 4 30 and then
and then i i had dreams that this is bad
and this is the first time that this has
happened but i started i did fall asleep
but then i started having dreams that i
was telling somebody how tired i was and
how i really wanted to sleep when i was
actually sleeping
yeah and then i woke up at 6 30 and i
got up i went for a walk
so yeah i'm exhausted okay
michael badgers there what's up bro
fourth row down says there was five
watching and then it went down to four
come back he said
it's back to seven well some people
don't have time you know what i mean
they come in and check it out they're
like
they're like oh they're talking about
cats again i'm out of here [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
yeah whatever we're just gonna talk
about pokey whether you like her yeah
it's okay how she woke us up at two
o'clock
that's all right saw a movie last night
i mostly saw it you didn't watch it i i
i couldn't get into it tom checked out
of it
this is a 2020 film and it's called the
droving
it is a british sort of folk horror
although i would say that it's more a
mystery
and it's actually listed as a mystery
thriller not as a horror movie
uh so know that going in uh basically
this is from uh this rubicon films and i
guess they made one called hex
that was similar like in a similar
location i'm not entirely sure where
they shot this i kind of feel like it
was maybe the north of england somewhere
but holy crap this is some landscape
porn if you want to see that [ __ ] this
is some gorgeous gorgeous like british
countryside and like mountains and stuff
like that nice cinematography i should
say
uh so the story of this is that there's
this guy named martin
and he's like uh an army guy i'm not
sure if he
you know is out of the army like
entirely now or if you know he's just on
leave or whatever
now a year prior to the events of the
film his sister megan
uh went missing while on a hiking trip
so basically the whole point of this
movie is martin
trying to kind of follow in her
footsteps and figure out what happened
to her
because she disappeared during this
town's annual uh
festival known as the droving which like
i said is kind of like
kind of like a little bit of a wicker
man situation i guess where everybody
puts like animal masks on
and they're gonna you know doing parades
and starting fires and stuff like that
is she being bad yeah i had to stop her
what are you doing back then tear off
those
[ __ ] shipping envelopes she loves
their shipping and
[ __ ] she's mad because she's like stop
doing the [ __ ] show
[Laughter]
she wants to wrestle we were playing
until you started brooklyn now you're
talking to the light box again
stop talking to the light bucks
doesn't make any sense she's uh
she's trying to get me to wrestle you
can wrestle with it
so yeah so oh my goodness so basically
this
this whole movie this whole movie
follows this guy
as he's kind of like like i said
following in his sister's foots of
trying to find out what happened to her
so he kind of like goes
you know he questions all the people
that are in the hiking group that last
saw the sister
and then he um you know runs in with
like these three guys with animal masks
on who lead them to some other guy and
then that guy leads him on another
so it's kind of like that now um i'm
gonna say
that i think i'm gonna recommend this
only to people who are into
um you know folk horror but also we're
into maybe
the witch or the ritual or something
like that because i will say
even for me this was a bit of a slow
burner
um like i said i wouldn't call it a
horror movie and it's not listed as one
it's actually
listed as a mystery which is more what
it is
there is some violence in it there is a
little bit of a supernatural element to
it
but that doesn't really come into it
until the end there's like a little bit
of a folkloric
type of element about a guy that can
supposedly like uh collect souls and
like bring people back from the dead
like if you collect souls from
for him and stuff and this is apparently
real but they
kind of leave it ambivalent as to
ambiguous rather like whether it's
real or not so as i said this could just
be a straight ahead
so basically the whole entire film is
following
martin so it's not only a mystery but
it's also kind of a character study
because pretty much you're just
following him throughout the whole thing
so most of the movie is just him going
from place to place and talking to
various people and getting
information about where his sister
disappeared to what happened to her like
what the [ __ ] is going on
you don't really get to see the droving
like the actual thing until the end
um you know the parades and everything
and like i said the cinematography and
this is really cool the acting is good
um the guy that played the old man was a
little
spotty but like the guy in the main uh
in the main
role whose name the actor's name is
daniel oldroyd um this was directed by
george popoff by the way who i think
he's done a couple other films but i
haven't seen them
um but you know the acting was generally
very good but like i said this is a very
low-key
uh mystery it's very dialogue heavy
there is some violence toward the end
like some kind of bloody
type of [ __ ] and a little bit of
supernatural type of stuff going on
but not real overtly horrific
you know what i mean it's one of those
ones where you really got it's like a
very quiet movie and you really have to
like pay attention to like all the
conversations and
and there's like a lot more you know
depth going on
the one thing that i don't think i'm not
saying i
don't know if i didn't like it or not
but it's just like i don't like
i don't think i like the way they
incorporated the flashbacks
with him and his sister like into the
story i think that could have been done
like in a slightly different way because
i think with because they kind of
started out with it and then
he had a beard like in the present time
for a second i didn't realize that was
the same dude
you know what i'm saying so i'm just
like wait a minute what who are these
people now and i was just kind of like
and then i said like after a minute like
it didn't take me that long to figure it
out
but um i'm not that dumb hopefully but
it's just like i didn't recognize him
for a second so i was just kind of like
well wait what does this thing have to
do with this other thing but then i was
just like oh okay i get it this is like
a flashback so like i said i don't know
if i would have done it precisely that
way there wasn't really any big kind of
like
and now i'm going to think about the
past and here we go so they didn't have
like any
there was just like another scene of
them and then suddenly there was a
flashback and so you know
so i don't know if i would have
integrated it quite in that way overall
um you know it was a pretty good movie
it was like i said it's
it's very slow and it was um very
much just kind of dialogue and landscape
and there were like some scenes that
were just like really really
just long conversations um you know or
long like
hikes of like people going through this
like you know beautiful landscapes and
stuff like that so
i mean if that sounds like something
that you'd be into then
you'd probably like it but if you want
something like super action-packed or
like super horrific or gory or anything
like that this is definitely not going
to be
your thing yeah i mean i'm not going to
[ __ ] on the movie
it didn't pull me in but it's not
because of the not because it's a bad
movie or anything it was
it was beautifully shot i mean intently
the acting was good
the storytelling is good for what it is
you know for that for that genre of
movie
the reason why i didn't like it it's not
my kind of movie yeah it's just not time
i kind of had as i suspected that it
wasn't like as soon as it started
my tastes are very american i like
spectacle
a lot of [ __ ] explosions humor [ __ ]
that pulls in lots of action early
you know something that a kid would like
that's what i like yeah so this is not
that this is a very
like i said it's a very slow a very
intimate movie
um it pretty much starts out like with
just conversation and just kind of a
slow pace
so which i think is good that they front
loaded it like that so you know what
you're getting into if you know you
don't like that kind of thing then
probably after five minutes you're gonna
be like [ __ ] this you're gonna turn it
off that's what i did you know what i
mean and yeah so tom checked out like in
the first five or ten minutes because
he's just like he he could see
the writing on the wall you can see
where i got a rule
in the first five or ten minutes i'll
never get in it yeah and it's
and it's [ __ ] consistent that rule is
like i said i can see why you wouldn't
uh
victor asked is it a new movie or an old
movie it's new um
it actually i've seen reviews of it i
think it just came out in 2020 i've seen
reviews of it from
april so maybe it came out around then i
think it's on amazon prime but i saw it
on toby
uh for free so if you want to watch it
on tubey you can do that like i said
i wouldn't i'm not not gonna recommend
it across the board
but if you like stuff like um
the witch or the ritual or
what is that [ __ ] movie i saw it like
a few years ago
it was an irish movie and it was about a
guy and he was like a tree surgeon
and he was out in this like kind of
remote
uh and he was like out in this remote
[ __ ] like trying to
they were gonna like tear some of the
forest down or something and he was like
trying to like
monitor the trees and then it was like
it was set in ireland and it was like
ireland there was like fairies there was
like changelings and stuff
it was it was a pretty good movie but it
was also a folk horror i don't know if
you saw it i might have watched it by
myself like on hulu
thing is about some of the folk horror
stuff like mid-summer
i watched it all the way through it i
enjoyed it which is weird because
i wouldn't like that kind of stuff yeah
because when we were in the theater i
was like oh my god tom's going to hate
this
i was surprised when you said that one
is that it was cons
the edit was very good it was
consistently getting weirder and they
were showing me stuff and it was getting
[ __ ] weirder and
i was going oh some bad [ __ ] happening
here so it pulled me into it
yeah this one didn't pull me into it
yeah all right and
i'm not gonna say it's the fault of the
movie maybe i think it's more of the
edit
and this is one that needs patience and
it's right and and and it's the kind of
the the content the story content of the
movie
i guess i guess it takes longer and it's
just it's just not my kind of story
commander sandy sito says is it the
hallow yes that is it i couldn't
remember the name of the one that i was
talking about with the changelings and
stuff
um yeah dk also said uh he recommended
hex
that also has the same actor in it yeah
that's the same production company i
don't know if it's the same director or
not
but um i've heard that that's good it's
set during the english civil war
um but i haven't seen that one yet but
yeah that's kind of along the same lines
as this
yeah um and oh and mango badger i was
just to mention this also check out a
field in england that is also very good
um if you want to watch that that might
be on tubey or
shutter or both i'm not real sure um i
watched it for the first time not too
long ago and i really really liked it um
it's pretty weird i don't know if you
would like it
so this just started oh this whole genre
kind of started it for me with the
wicker man
yeah and that's the kind of blood on
satan's claw that's kind of like the the
that was kind of like the the foundation
of these kind of movies for me
i always compare it to that um
miss summer i thought compared favorably
to uh
to to the array it had a lot of the same
vibe now the remake of the
the remake of the [ __ ] wicker man
[ __ ] sucked but the original
yeah that was really good like
especially for the funny but not
intentionally yeah
more better for the time and i thought
mid-summer was a good [ __ ] update to
that
if you guys haven't seen that if you
liked the wicker man and
and you liked it see mid-summer one of
the summer's [ __ ] weird it's
one of the best things about mid-summer
other than it being like set in the day
and still being creepy as [ __ ] which is
really hard to do creepy ass white
people that's the [ __ ] hole
yeah but like i really liked that they
almost kind of like there was
like the violence was very restrained
but when you saw it it was like
really nasty like those [ __ ] old
people
like jumping off the cliff instead that
was gross
that that that [ __ ] type of of um
what'd you call it what's that shower
again the what horror the [ __ ] flow
chord
that's i guess that's the way to put it
because it kind of goes with some of
that
post-industrial folk gothic music you
know like current 93
and yeah yeah you know death in june and
stuff you know where it's [ __ ] kind
of germanic and norse and old pagan [ __ ]
the the deal with that movie the the
attraction of those movies
is that they're kind of like it's white
people being ancient weird-ass [ __ ]
white
that's what it's about okay it's the
white he's gonna white
yes why did he whiten his ass off and
it's [ __ ]
it's it's the white version of a [ __ ]
voodoo movie
that's what it is or like the white
version of like a wendigo
are we go i well that is white though
you have i'm talking about white europe
i'm talking no i'm talking about
black people okay [ __ ]
these movies are kind of like the white
version of [ __ ] voodoo movies and
haitian voodoo and zombie type movies
what it is it's black people with
witchcraft
and white people with witchcraft that's
the the difference
but it's that same concept
you know what i mean you're scaring the
[ __ ] out of white people by look at this
yeah man
look at what you're eating look at what
people are
still doing they will [ __ ] tie people
up [ __ ] put them in a house and set
it on fire along with the animals
because that's what nature wants that's
what god wants it's just weird concepts
like that it's time that we all have
group sex
weird [ __ ] like that wait what yeah
outside
outside goddess says that's with the old
ladies
all women having sex with you outside
because with the swords like
symbolically yeah cutting the heads up
what's going on
and there is i don't know what it is but
there is something very unsettling about
people wearing
animal heads not like in a you know oh
furries because i know everybody's gonna
say that but it's like that's not really
unsettling
but [ __ ] like i mean if you guys have
ever seen the silent movie uh hexane
uh the swedish one very famous um it has
like a scene in it
where and this was made in like [ __ ]
1919 or 1920 or something like
some you know like a century ago and
there's a scene in it where there's like
a like the door of a castle and there's
like a person on either side like with a
person like wearing an animal head and
it's still [ __ ] creepy
i don't know why it's just there's
something really creepy about
um and i have to say too that in this
particular movie the droving
um there's not like i said i don't i
think i would have liked a little bit
more of
the droving in it like a little bit more
of the celebration a little bit more of
the masks and stuff
one of the scenes early on with like
these three thugs that have like their
uh droving costumes on those are the
costumes are like really cool especially
the one that looks kind of like a
like a malamute or like a husky or
something it's like
a little unsettling and then they had
one that was like a black bird and
i can't remember what the other one was
but um it would have been cool if they'd
done like a little bit more with that
because i feel like this you know it
it's about
a cult and it's about like a an occult
ritual but it's mostly just about this
one guy and what happened to the sister
and then it was just like
and it wasn't even really ended up being
like spoiler alert
it didn't even end up really being about
a cult or anything it was just like this
one guy and
um a legend that actually turned out to
possibly be true
and why and so he kind of went off the
beat so it was just like one dude really
you know what i'm saying but i just i
just trip out on this scandinavian
concept of [ __ ] killing people so
[ __ ] grows
it's just you know that's some weird
[ __ ] yeah it's like it's weird when you
think about it because i guess i can see
where that idea comes from the aztecs
kind of had it
if you don't know anything about how
things work like how things work in
reality like
of science or anything and you're just
kind of like working off what you can
see like in front of your face
yeah um i can see people coming to that
conclusion yeah
i mean the aztecs were sacrificing
children so the parents would cry
and crying would make the cods cry so
therefore it would cause it to rain
see that it kind of makes total sense
yeah i mean
in a way that doesn't but i mean you
know what i mean it's then imagine you
got to go out and do that
sorry we gotta [ __ ] kill your
children so it rains
i mean there had to be like people had
some of people had to feel bad about it
yeah they did but they thought they had
to keep that but they thought they had
they had to do it to keep the [ __ ]
running
so i can i read the stuff the [ __ ]
hernan cortez and the guys that were
with him tried to explain to him that
they didn't have to do it and
they just couldn't they they couldn't
there's like yeah we do they couldn't
believe it
that the world wouldn't fall apart if
they weren't doing it
and you know they kept going back to it
and some of the friars and the
conquistadors would jump on them and
kill people for
sacrificing their children and sometimes
they were [ __ ]
mutilating them for doing it they were
just they were using corporal punishment
and sometimes you know capital
punishment to keep people from stop
sacrificing other people took
generations it doesn't happen overnight
well that's the thing if you get an idea
so ingrained in your head and your
culture and it's reinforced every day
because that's
you don't really like run into any
outsiders quote unquote that like
i got caught of ocelot in there you know
this that's my [ __ ] boy from mexico
and you know so i'm partially bringing
that up to him he knows about it too me
and him are into that into that
mesoamerican stuff and um
what was weird is that hernan's take on
it was very modern he was saying and he
was trying hernan was trying to explain
to a lot of the mesoamericans that these
religions were put in by the ruling
class to keep control of them and that
it was just a way of giving a religious
authority to the ruling class
to select who would be sacrificed and
they could control an
entire tribe because that king of that
tribe was afraid that his daughter his
son would come up next for sacrifice
so if you disobeyed you know what i mean
that's pretty insightful for uh
yeah figure that out you know and that's
it right
basically what quartet cortez is
describing
a totalitarian system a totalitarian
theocracy
and um he was using he was using that
concept before those phrases
those terms had been coined yeah which
hey man if i could say what you want
about cortez man [ __ ]
that dude got that job he was no dummy
he was no [ __ ] dummy
no dummy and and probably wanted to
and he was a mercenary that was a thing
he was a mercenary soldier probably one
of the greatest mercenaries in all of
human history
and got cheated out of his [ __ ] claim
too but that's another that's another
story
kind of odds on us says apocalypto is a
good movie yeah yeah it is a fantastic
movie actually
apocalypto is kind of like we own that
don't we uh no maybe i do own that if
not i got it i thought we did if not i
got to get apocalypto
is is is the mexican version of one of
these folk
uh movies that we had yeah basically
what it is that's what it is
it's weird i would have thought that i
mean maybe there have been more recently
but i would have thought that there
would be
folk horror i feel like should be a
larger genre
you know what i'm saying like everybody
every time somebody thinks talks about
folk horror it's like the first one you
think
of your go-to is wicker man um obviously
there was also blood on satan's claw
like i said from uh
that was also a british movie and then
you know
as i said there have been a few like
over the past few years you had
mid-summer you had the
the hallow which was irish um they come
up every now and then but i just
the ritual i guess was kind of one like
that i feel like it's such a creepy
i've always been creeped out by like
folk [ __ ] and it just surprises me that
it's not a bigger sub genre i wonder why
that is maybe other people aren't
creeped out by
by it as much as god's going on about
how [ __ ] cortez was hooking up with
with lola malenchy i think her name was
that was his
that was his little mesoamerican
princess
she was having his children though too
and evidently
she was with him for life you know that
was a true relationship i believe
yeah they stayed together forever um so
in a way in a lot of ways cortez's
children were the first modern of
mexicans really
yeah which were you know there's a lot
of spanish blood going on
especially you start getting towards
mexico city but that's just you know
that's how history played out yeah yeah
commander
sunny sito says population 436 sounds
like a movie you folks might like have
you seen it i have not seen it yet
i have a humongous list of movies i have
to see that's as long as my arm
new ones old ones all kind of [ __ ]
yeah but yeah i mean you know if it
sounds like something i might like then
i will definitely check it out in fact
i'm going to write it down
right now which reminds me i told you to
remind me and you didn't
but i need to do shout outs oh we got
gotta do the shout outs we've got
i forgot to do them yesterday and like
some people have
sent us things and i forgot to say about
it we got gifts from the people we got
gifts from the people
yeah first of all i'd like to give a
thank you to
michael who was sent oh my goodness yeah
who sent us the steel book
yes friday the 13th special edition
steel book special edition 40th
anniversary thank you very much
love it look look at this i love this i
love this yeah
isn't that awesome yeah i love that so
much and uh also
i wanted to thank these were from
dominic yeah uh we got the texas
chainsaw massacre
remake that's a remake that's supposed
to be good jenny said it was uh i
actually
i actually really liked it i saw it in
the theater and then i saw it again on
cable and i'm like wow that was like way
better than i was expecting it to be uh
and
seven yeah remember that one that's good
what's in the box what's in the box
yeah you have to do that every time you
talk about seven yeah
that's the rule no uh yeah that was it
that
that
that
that
that
that
that
that that that that was oh um another thing
is
that the director from um cruel peter uh
thanked us for our
review yeah i got a message from like he
was either the director the producer i
can't really remember he had worked on
cruel peter
and i guess because remember we reviewed
that like yeah it was probably a couple
months ago it's a good movie it looks
great
i liked it it was very like still i love
all that old gothic
yeah that old gothic horror like a
little creepy old mansion that [ __ ] i
love that [ __ ]
creepy characters yeah so yeah it was
really good so i thought it was really
cool he just sent me a
brief message like thanking me for
reviewing the movie and stuff and i'm
like hey man
right it was a good movie so good on you
all right
so uh i guess that'll do it for our
wednesday look into we'll see we'll see
bill bill and ted soon i'll
we'll watch it yeah cause it's like i
saw it it's for rent but you still gotta
pay like 20 bucks it's like 20 bucks to
see it yeah i don't know if i want to
con
down there and tj get the bootlegs
i know what you're doing dude i know
what you're doing
you can get it like you know yeah from
like some places but i don't know i've
i've heard like most people seem to
think is pretty good so you know and i
like the first time right they want 25
dollars to see that 25
five dollars i think i'll wait until it
comes down to maybe about
do you know how much vodka i can buy for
25
well here's the deal why don't they give
you the blu-ray for that
that's what the blu-ray would cost
that's true yeah
well you can i think on the xbox you can
either buy it like you can buy the
additional copy
or you can rent the vision the digital
copy it seems dumb just like to have
to pay the same amount you can buy a
physical copy
i don't think so i think you can buy the
digital the digital copy
well i don't know if the physical
company is out yet i would want the
physical [ __ ] you for 25 bucks i want
a physical [ __ ] yeah i want to
hold it
i don't want you to be able to like take
it away or decide i can't actually kind
of want both i want the digital and the
and
the blu-ray because usually they'll come
with a digital copy yeah i mean speaking
of uh
speaking of movies that are if you guys
have wanted to see color out of space
which we reviewed
shutter just got it it's on shutter now
we actually bought
the blu-ray did we not yeah yeah i think
we bought the blu-ray uh
pre-ordered it when it came out so we
already have it but um you know if you
don't have it if you wanted to see it
then it's on shutter if you have shutter
and shutter's only [ __ ] five dollars
a month so you need to get on that shirt
for six dollars a month however much of
it you just can't beat shutter
and i mean i i pay for it annually so
it's cheaper
i think it's only 59 a year something
like that it's like super cheap
and they added yeah they added uh color
out of space
uh bram stoker's dracula the one with uh
gary oldman
and they also added the vampire lovers
and one other old vampire one
yeah vampire lovers that's a hammer
right i think it's
gonna be or it's hammer adjacent i can't
remember gonna be plenty of cleavage in
that one that's a good movie actually
yeah
i think is that those is that the one
i'm thinking of did we [ __ ] review
that
that's the one that's um about count as
bathroom i thought
yeah probably either that or it's based
on uh carmilla
i get it confused there's so many
vampire movies that came out around that
time all right so um
we're gonna wrap this up we uh we'll
probably not live stream again tomorrow
and or friday as usual uh we're gonna
live stream for the saturday show the
regular episode
and uh the votes came in so we have the
topic
should be a fun one i think i think
it'll be a fun show
it's not good it's not a depressing show
not well i guess it kind of is but you
know
our shows are always surprising all
right so uh we'll talk to you guys
again and we'll see you on saturday for
yet another live stream and thanks for
dropping bye